On August 21, people across the United States
will be able to witness a total solar eclipse.
As the moon passes in front of the sun and
casts a shadow over the Earth. Although total
solar eclipses occur regularly across the
planet, they very rarely recur in the same
location. As the path of the moon's shadow,
or umbra, only covers a narrow portion of
the Earth. Nevertheless, scientists throughout
history have used these celestial events to
help us understand more about our planet,
the solar system and the universe beyond.
The total eclipse of the moon back in the
16th century was used to make the first measurement
of the width of the Atlantic ocean. Settlers
from Britain had landed in Virginia in the
United States and the question was, where
were they? It was possible to work out the
latitude because you can work out from the
height of the sun at midday exactly how far
north of the equator you are. But how far
across the globe they've gone? How far their
longitude was? How do you do that? Well a
total eclipse of the moon, or any eclipse
of the moon, is visible over the whole of
the night time side of the Earth. So in London
they measured the time when the eclipse started
or finished according to our clocks and then
in Virginia they did likewise with their clocks.
And then they came back and told the people
in London what time it happened according
to them from which they worked out that it
was a five hours time difference.
Using this, they could then use their knowledge
of longitude and time to calculate the distance.
But scientists have also used these events
to better understand the dynamics of our solar
system. In particular Edmond Halley.
Who back calculated the dates of the eclipses
in the past. Because eclipses have been recorded
throughout history whenever they happened.
And he found that according to his calculations,
the further he went back there was a mismatch
between the date when they were recorded and
the date when his calculations said they should
have happened. His calculations just assumed
that the moon was going around the Earth in
a regular trajectory that never changes. And
he deduced that this regular change throughout
history, going back in history, was because
the moon's orbit is changing. Technically,
the moon is gradually getting further away
from the Earth. I think it's at about the
rate that your nails grow. So that is a remarkable
example of science making use of this natural
phenomenon.
It also means that after a certain point total
solar eclipses will no longer exist as the
moon will be too far away to completely block
out the sun's light.
But in 1919, a solar eclipse provided the
opportunity to test out a revolutionary new
theory - the test of general relativity. Where
according to Einstein's theory light is bent
by gravitational forces and the sun, which
is the biggest source of gravity in the solar
system, should therefore bend the trajectory
of light rays.
The theory suggested that the sun's gravity
could bend the light of nearby stars around
its mass. So that stars behind the sun would
be visible to us on Earth. Although Newton's
established theory also allowed for this,
Einstein's modified theory of gravity suggested
that it would occur at twice the amount. The
only problems was that the intensity of the
sun's light, would outshine any starlight
travelling close by, making it impossible
to test under normal conditions. It was only
in the brief period of a total solar eclipse,
about seven minutes, that gravitationally
shifted stars might be detected. No pressure
then.
But British astronomer Arthur Eddington took
up this challenge and sailed to West Africa
where he could get the best view of the eclipse.
Eddington took photographs of the total eclipse
of the stars in the background because you
can see the stars during totality. And indeed
the measurements confirmed Einstein's theory.
And this what he photographed. Including in
his paper that: "a deflection of light takes
place in the neighbourhood of the sun and
that it is of the amount demanded by Einstein's
generalised theory of relativity".
And it's all down to some measurements made
in the seven minute window.
Scientists are still using total solar eclipses
today to learn about how the sun works. In
particular to study its corona. A very tenuous,
very hot gas, which only about one millionth
of the intensity in light terms of the glowing
ball of the sun. The shapes and the lines
of the corona are showing what the nature
of the sun's magnetic field is at that time.
During a total eclipse, when the central sun
is obscured, then this tenuous corona is visible.
And so, on August 21, NASA will be flying
two jets to chase the path of totality across
North America. Providing seven minutes to
capture infrared measurements of the sun's
corona. As well as taking opportunity to generate
the first ever thermal map of mercury.
And so after centuries of eclipse events,
it seems kind of humbling that scientists
are still using them to inform our understanding
of the solar system.